sebastian's with us in tampa florida
good afternoon sebastian how can chrissy
and i help
hey how you guys doing a huge fan um
so i have one quick question i have um
one debt it's to my grandparents and
they're really nice about it like
they're not rushing me but it's one of
those things that like
when you sit next to them at dinner it
just food don't taste as good because i
know i owe them that money
um it's three thousand dollars and i
have a thousand dollars right now
saved to pay them back so i make 15 an
hour at my job right now working 33
hours a week and i'm going to school
no student debt i've been cashflowing
that um
i have a side hustle of reselling shoes
like nikes adidas all that
so my main question was i want to kind
of
take it to the next level with reselling
shoes because i've had like
pretty decent success but to do that i
need to invest in a computer so that i
can run
like softwares like to act like people
so i could pick up more shoes
and the issue with that is a computer
for that
is very specific so i need to build it
and that's 1500
but i know like my profit margin would
be
really like a guaranteed because i
already know how to use most that stuff
i just don't have the computer would it
be wise to
go ahead and invest in the computer
before paying my grandparents off
so that i could like pay them back
faster or should i just keep saving up
as i've been doing
to pay them back how so the thousand
dollars is is your total savings
that's all the things what i've been uh
i've been saving up for
probably the past like three weeks and
that's what i've gotten so far
okay help me understand this software
i'm not disagreeing i just don't
understand it tell me what you are going
to be able to do
uh with this computer and software that
you can't do right now on your phone
just being scrappy manual hustling
getting it done
okay so what it is it's called box so
i bought i would i i'm in a cook group
which is like i can rent bots prefer
let's say anywhere from 50 to 240
depending on how good of a software i
want
and what that software will do is on
this computer i could have like
instead of one tab open that is for me
to add a shoe to a cart
i can have 100 to 200 tabs open
and be able to get multiple pairs to
resell
oh so you're trying to get you know
fancy
you're just you're trying to turn these
shoes faster yeah
yeah i have friends that they're already
into this and i see the numbers that
they're able to pull
off from it but i don't have a computer
that's capable of having
that many tabs open and i can run boss
on
all right here's what i want you to do i
want to challenge you on something
sebastian i'm not against
you getting this computer and this
software but i want you to do two things
before you do
the first thing i want you to do is i
want you to if you have a friend that is
truly doing this
either ask them if you can borrow it for
a day for an hour i want you to prove
that you can do this
i want you to actually test the software
and prove to yourself
that you can turn this profit that you
think you can before you drop 1500
into it i just want you to test it out
however you go about that whether it's a
friend or
whatever you do i just want you to test
it the second thing if that works and
you're like yeah this is def i've
validated my idea i definitely can get
it i want you to sit down with your
grandparents
tell them your plan and ask their
permission
for you to make this expense with the
intention of you want to pay them off
sooner i want them to feel a part of the
decision
since you're in debt to them just out of
respect for them and for your
own conscience that you're not sitting
down at dinner feeling like you just
bought this software and feeling even
worse about it and you hid it from them
so i just want you to take a couple
steps and then
the other thing is if you decide to do
it they're good with it you prove your
idea
i want you to set a goal that you are
going to turn
you are going to pay that back to
yourself you're going to make that much
money back
in less than three months i want you i
want you to invest
and that that's why i was um kind of
hesitant instead of just jumping into it
because
i don't want them to think that like oh
he just spent this much money on a
computer and he's not paying us back
like i saw that i set a budget and it's
like
if i do if i live by my budget which
i've been really like been strict to
myself about it
i could have everything paid off to them
in three months and i was like oh maybe
if i can invest into this i can have it
paid back in like two months
all right but like you said i would have
to talk to them first about it well
but here's the thing you're in school
you're cash flowing you've got a side
hustle you're a driven guy
you're not just sitting around eating
popcorn expecting people to make a way
for you you're
you're trying and i and i hear that in
your voice and see it
in what you've already done i just want
to make sure when you do this you're up
front with your
grandparents you're clear and prove your
idea that you can do it and then you
hold your feet to the fire to get it
done in two months three months
something like that
and i think you will i think if you do
that that's the right way to go about it
to get it paid off even faster
so bash let me ask you this what what
was the three thousand dollars for that
your
parents loaned you the money for so um
last year i actually moved out to go to
school in gainesville
um and so i didn't have a job when i
first went there
and so i had to pay my own rent i had to
pay
for food and i made really bad decisions
and i joined the fraternity which i knew
i couldn't afford but i still did it
anyway
um i wasn't listening to you guys
obviously
and so now that it's like that i am i'm
like man i really
should not have done that because that
was like 1500 on its own
so luckily my grandparents they helped
me and they're like hey
you can pay this back uh whenever you're
able to but this is so that you can like
keep going to school over there um since
then i'm back home
ever since my classes went online for
covid so i don't have to worry about
paying rent or anything like that thank
god
so you're at um your home your home
doing online school
yes so that means you haven't you have
access to a computer
i have a computer but it's it's like
eight years old and it's not something i
could run
right now no no no no no no no no
this this computer won't hold have that
software you can make this work yeah you
you you can make this work uh sebastian
yeah i thought he didn't have a computer
ao
i mean we just had to ask the right
questions here's my thing man um
you know i was agreeing with christy
until you said you had a computer uh i i
don't
i don't sell shoes you know same um i
don't love the business
you can sell shoes and you may not be
able to sell it as fast as your friends
but right now i think you have to really
lay down some priorities
you you borrow money from your mom your
parents
so you could join a fraternity you need
to pay them back okay
it's time for you to step up to be a man
say you know what let me do what i got
to do
pay them back and then if you want to
save up to get the computer a better
computer to sell more shoes
then you do that but i think the first
step to being a man
is paying the people use what you've got
i if you've got a computer you got a
phone use what you've got to do what you
want to do then you can upgrade it